President Trump is set to reverse nearly
seven decades of us Middle East policy
today he is expected to announce that
Washington will recognize Jerusalem as
Israel's capital the president plans to
tell the State Department to begin the
process of moving the US Embassy from
Tel Aviv Seth Doane is in Jerusalem
where Israel's prime minister did not
mention the issue this morning but first
let's go to Margaret Brennan at the
White House for more on this decision
Margaret good morning good morning no
other country in the world has an
embassy in Jerusalem but today President
Trump will make a major concession and
recognize Jerusalem as the political
capital of Israel he'll promise that in
the future a US Embassy will be built
there we will move the American Embassy
to the eternal capital of the Jewish
people Jerusalem that campaign pledge
popular with evangelicals and hardline
Israel supporters is why President Trump
will recognize Jerusalem as Israeli
territory against the advice of allies
and his national security team
if you can't in the Middle East it also
undermines the peace process launched by
Jared Kushner as the status of Jerusalem
is one of the most incendiary issues in
the conflict for nearly 70 years US
policy has been to settle it through
diplomacy my administration will always
stand with Israel security alerts were
sent to u.s. posts around the world to
brace for violence ahead of mr. Trump's
declaration president Trump has boasted
about his chance at peace but four of
the five world leaders he spoke with
Tuesday said this would be a setback
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas
cautioned it would have quote
detrimental consequences on the peace
process White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders downplayed it they spoke
with five liters that's hardly
indicative of everybody across the globe
as for that peace plan the Trump
administration has yet to present any
proposal saying Jared Kushner's team
figuring it out for now the US Embassy
stays in Tel Aviv the White House says
that building a new one will take at
least four years through the end mr.
Trump's first term Gayle all right
Margaret thank you very much